Bitcoin is generally thought to be the og
cryptocurrency having been created way back
in 2009.
But, this is actually not true.
In fact, a computer scientist named Nick Szabo
designed a cryptocurrency based on blockchain
technology 11 years earlier in 1998.
If you take a closer look at this cryptocurrency,
you’ll see that it’s hauntingly similar
to Bitcoin.
It even has a very similar name having been
called Bit Gold.
Considering these glaring similarities, many
have speculated that Nick Szabo is actually
the anonymous creator of Bitcoin.
So, here’s the story of Bit Gold and some
evidence that Nick Szabo may actually be the
creator of Bitcoin.
Nick Szabo was a highly educated man having
earned both a computer science degree and
a law degree Aside from this, Nick was fairly
well known within the academic community for
his research into digital contracts and digital
currency.
He even received an honorary professorship
from Universidad Francisco Marroquin for his
research.
Considering Nick’s background, it’s not
surprising that he eventually tried to create
his own digital currency.
Similar to Bitcoin, Nick wanted to create
a form a digital currency that was completely
decentralized.
You see, Nick was not impressed whatsoever
by the traditional financial system as it
is not only inefficient but also quite vulnerable.
One of Nick’s main arguments against the
traditional financial system is that there
is too much trust involved in just a handful
of institutions.
Take loans for instance.
First, people depositing money into the bank
have to trust that the bank will lend and
invest their money safely.
Next, when a bank is giving out a loan, they
have to trust that the borrowers credit score
is accurately calculated.
Finally, the lender also has to trust that
the borrower will pay back the loan.
Even if all of this goes smoothly, everyone
has to trust that the currency itself has
value.
The significant amount of trust in a handful
of institutions makes the entire system much
easier to manipulate.
For instance, a credit score institution could
lie about a person’s credit score or a bank
could give out risky loans like during the
subprime mortgage crisis or the federal reserve
could just start printing ludicrous amounts
of money.
With a decentralized system, however, a single
person or entity having too much power is
far less likely.
Nick’s proposal to accomplish this was leveraging
the proof of work model.
Nick suggested that this model could be setup
through a peer to peer network called a Byzantine
Fault Tolerant or BFT.
His plan consisted of individuals around the
world using computing power to solve cryptographic
puzzles.
The first individual to solve the puzzle would
end up validating a set of transactions and
they would receive a small amount of bit gold
for their contribution.
This entire process is called the proof of
work model and it’s one way to verify cryptocurrency
transactions.
For those of you who are familiar with bitcoin
mining, this entire description likely sounded
eerily similar.
That’s because the proof of work model is
used to this day to mine Bitcoin and Ethereum.
Most cryptocurrencies are switching over to
a proof of stake model as it’s a much more
energy efficient method of verification.
But the simple fact that Bitcoin is still
using the proof of work model shows how far
ahead Nick was thinking.
Despite this though, Nick would run into a
major obstacle with Bit Gold which was the
threat of double spending.
As the name suggests, double spending is the
threat that an individual could spend the
same digital currency twice.
For instance, a person could use some Bit
Gold to buy some bread at a grocery store.
The person coud then turn around and replicate
the code behind the Bit Gold that he just
spent and then spend the replicated Bit Gold
to buy a taco at a restaurant.
This issue could easily be fixed by establishing
a central authority that confirmed the validity
of each transaction, but that would be counterintuitive
as the currency would no longer be decentralized.
Bitcoin would eventually fix this issue by
leveraging block confirmations.
Block confirmations consist of simply writing
each transaction onto the blockchain.
The more blocks that are mined and added to
the blockchain, the more difficult it becomes
reverse a previously completed transaction
and double spend.
Double spending wasn’t the only obstacle
Nick faced though.
Bit Gold’s reliance on a Byzantine Fault
Tolerant made the system vulnerable to Sybil
attacks.
A Sybil attack is simply when a user creates
a boatload of fake accounts or profiles to
manipulate a network.
It’s kind of like the bots in the comment
section that try to convince you that joining
Mary Jane’s whatsapp group made them a millionaire.
Anyway, in terms of a blockchain network,
a Sybil attack is when a single user tries
to run multiple nodes on the blockchain in
order to influence other nodes and prevent
data from being added to the network.
Bitcoin actually never really solved this
issue, they just made it extremely expensive
to conduct a sybil attack.
A person’s influnce within the Bitcoin universe
is limited by how much computing power they
have.
So, a person can’t just go out a create
a bunch of nodes for free.
They would have to go out and buy a bunch
of computing power.
If an individual or group is able to take
control of 50% or more of a blockchain network’s
hash rate, then they could go ahead and carry
out a 51% attack on the crypto.
Many smaller cryptos are extremely susceptible
to this sort of attack and it’s actually
rather common.
Bitcoin could technically still be 51% attacked
as well, but it would likely have to conducted
by someone like China as such an operation
would likely cost tens of billions.
Anyway, Nick wasn’t able to fully solve
the double spending problem at the time and
he knew that Sybil and 51% attacks were serious
threats.
So, he would never end up releasing Bit Gold
to the public.
But, Bit Gold isn’t Nick’s only contribution
to the crypto space.
Nick’s other known contribution to the space
is smart contracts.
Smart contracts are a way to enforce the terms
of a contract through the blockchain network
and a code.
Generally, whenever a financial agreement
is made, there is some sort of overseeing
authority.
For instance, with banking, the government
oversees a bank’s activities.
The government sets minimum reserve limits
and they insure credible financial institutions.
This is supposed to give depositors peace
of mind and some sense of security.
In a decentralized system though, there is
no overseeing authority.
Nick’s solution to this conundrum is making
blockchain technology the overseeing authority.
With smart contracts, terms of a financial
contract will be translated into code and
computers will ensure that the agreed upon
terms are carried out.
A simple example of a potential usecase of
a smart contract is life insurance.
When a life insurance policy is signed, the
terms of the contract will be coded into the
blockchain.
After this, computers will automatically charge
the policy holder the specified amount every
month.
And, when the policy holder dies and a death
certificate is provided, the computer will
release the payment to the beneficiaries.
So, Bit Gold and smart contracts are the two
primary known contributions from Nick.
But, the question remains, is Bitcoin an unrecognized
contribution from Nick?
Well, there’s actually a decent amount of
circumstantial evidence that suggests this
starting with of course Nick’s background.
Whoever created Bitcoin has to be extremely
forward looking as they created Bitcoin way
back in 2009.
Given that Nick proposed smart contracts in
1997 and Bit Gold in 1998, he was definitely
capable of creating Bitcoin in 2009.
Bitcoin’s code also often praised for being
extremely well developed meaning that Bitcoin
was either developed by several professionals
or it took years to develop.
Maybe it took Nick 11 years to perfect Bitgold
and turn it into Bitcoin.
The similarities between the name Bitgold
and Bitcoin itself suggest that they may be
related.
What’s even more interesting though is the
similarities between Nick’s name and the
alias name of Bitcoin’s quote on quote Japanese
founder Satoshi Nakamoto.
This means that his initials are SN from a
western perspective, but Japan actually follows
the Eastern name order where the last name
is placed first when writing initials.
This means that Satoshi’s initials are actually
NS. Satoshi even confirmed that these were
indeed his initials in an email he sent to
Hal Finney.
In this email, Satoshi describes how his bitcoin
address happened to start with his initials.
If we take a look at the respective bitcoin
address, we’ll see that his intitals are
indeed NS.
If you haven’t noticed yet, that’s the
same as Nick Szabo.
Not only are the initials the same, but the
names even sound similar.
The first syllable of Nakamoto is Nak which
is very similar to Nick.
Also, the first part of Satoshi is Sato which
is very similar to Szabo.
Another notable coincidence is Satoshi’s
birthday which is on April 5, 1975.
The significance of this date is that gold
ownership was banned in the US on April 5,
1933 and it was removed in 1975.
So, the birthday is kind of a combination
of the two dates.
But what’s interesting though is that Nick’s
birthday is also on April 5.
That’s definitely quite a coincidence.
Moving on, we even have evidence of what seems
like Nick covering up his tracks.
In 2005, Nick made a blog post that described
the merits of Bit Gold and how an unforgeable
chain could be used to increase security.
At the top of the blog post though, you’ll
see that the date of publication is December
27, 2008.
But this is actually not true, Nick actually
made this post in 2005.
The URL still even says 2005.
So, why did Nick go back and change the date?
Well, maybe he changed the date in order to
cover up the fact that he basically outlined
the entirety of bitcoin 3 years before Satoshi
outlined the same things in 2008.
Something else that’s super suspicious is
that Nick became extremely quite after Bitcoin
came out.
Before the release of Bitcoin, Nick generally
made a blog post every other week.
After Bitcoin came out though, his posting
dwindled to just a couple per year.
Perhaps, the most convincing piece of evidence
though is a major Freudian Slip.
A Freudian slip is an unintentional error
that’s reveals a person’s subconscious
thoughts.
In an interview with Tim Ferriss in 2017,
Nick Szabo would accidentally say that he
designed bitcoin and then promptly correct
it to Bit Gold.
Despite this correction though, Nick would
continue to talk about Bitcoin instead of
Bit gold and he would even use the word “we”.
At the end of the day, Nick Szabo is a brilliant
computer scientist who was developing digital
currencies and block chain technology way
back in the 1990s.
His first known attempt at a cryptocurrency
was with Bit Gold.
The official story is that he wasn’t able
to solve the security risks and so the project
failed.
But did Bit Gold really fail?
Or did it just evolve into the most popular
cryptocurrency in the world?
Let me know in the comments down below.
Also drop a like if you guys found this video
rather intriguing.
And of course, consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.